how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
musical philosophy first of all how that
I guess in the late of it confines
conception of religion is really quite
controversial because he manages to
antagonize if you like two of the most
entrenched camps at the same time sort
of the kind of if you like Orthodox
religious believers who want some kind
of literal construe love religious
language and perhaps the more militant
atheists who want to be able to say well
we can use science to disprove religious
claims or it's just obvious that
religious language is unintelligible or
it's incoherent because the claims about
God don't make any sense and there's no
such entity and so on so so if you're
like what what Wittgenstein is doing
similarly actually to how he tackles
philosophical problems in in the later
work more generally he always tries to
undermine both sides of these kinds of
debates so he's putting forward a
position that comes down on neither one
side nor the other rather he wants to
open up the conceptual space for another
possible third option and in this case
the third option would be to get away
from the thought that religious language
can only mean something by way of
referring to supernatural entities for
example so given that the later
Wittgenstein thinks that meaning is
primarily use we have to actually look
at how religious language is used in the
particular religious practices in order
to be able to understand what religious
terms mean so it's not enough just to
look at a sentence straight off and
think well okay you know you're talking
about some bizarre entity that is
supposed to be doing really strange
things and anyone can understand the
sentence straight off so in the English
speaker can
understand an English sentence about God
vet control would deny that I mean he
wouldn't deny that you know you can make
some sense if the sentence obviously you
can understand what the ordinary
meanings of the words comprising the the
religion the religious utterance are but
you don't necessarily understand the
full significance because you're taking
it out of context you're not looking at
the role it actually plays within as
Wittgenstein would say the religious
language game as a whole so just to give
you an example you know religious
speakers sometimes use phrases like gods
re sees everything now in in this case
you know it's probably fairly obvious
that this is a metaphor and you know
therefore not to be taken literally but
you know if we use the model religious
languages primarily to be taken
literally well then you would think you
know what what's the kind of literal
content of God's eye sees everything
well done
God has a single eye and that this eye
is equipped in a supernaturally bizarre
way so that it can actually see
everything contrary to any kind of
physical eye imaginable but clearly I
mean if you thought that that's what the
sentence meant you kind of be missing
the point of what this religious
utterance is really doing so if you look
at the use to which the phrase is put
within religious practice you're going
to realize fairly quickly that what the
sentence really means is to act as a
form of admonishment to really kind of
say you know God is always watching you
or you can't hide your sins from God or
you know something along those lines so
that that's just an example of the sort
of thing that that bit constrain has in
mind that you might you know be misled
as he would put it by the surface
grammar of you know what the same thing
superficially looks like but it doesn't
mean that you necessarily understand the
depth grammar ie what's actually going
on underneath the surface and for that
you have to look at the wider context
you have to look at the use to which
these kinds of expressions are put
within a particular religious community
and so on so it's not as easy as just
the
King upwards and saying well this makes
sense and this doesn't I mean if it were
that easy then you probably could just
say well okay this looks incoherent so
we can just dismiss religion but it can
shine thinks that's making it too easy
for yourself that's taking the lazy
option they can find basically thinks
that religion is neither rational nor
irrational he thinks it's a rational so
you don't believe necessarily for
particular rational reasons but neither
are your beliefs necessarily irrational
now he's not saying that any religious
belief automatically falls into the the
non rational category because he does
think that some religious believers are
for example confused about what they
believe so if you like the honest
religious believer who isn't deceiving
him or herself about their beliefs would
probably fall into the the non rational
category but people that bit control
would probably characterize as being
superstitious that wouldn't qualify as
genuinely religious in in vet conjoin
sense so you know if you think for
example that there is evidence for
religious claims evidence sort of
analogous to the kind of empirical
evidence we can have in the sciences say
then that constrain thinks that's that's
basically cheating yourself pretending
that evidence is available where it's
not so again quite controversially and
radically he thinks religious beliefs
are not based on evidence and of course
normally especially in philosophy you
know philosophers tend to think well
well we quite quite reasonably you know
if you believe and can't offer rational
grounds for your belief then your belief
is irrational so one might think so that
that's that's the other side the other
side might say well you know if it can
Stein is right and it's really non
rational and I can't deduce any rational
reasons they should I really be a
believer so that that's that's a
difficult question I think there is an
answer to it I think
Wittgenstein can get round the problem
because as long as you're honest about
the lack of evidence I mean you're not
kind of pretending there is evidence
available when there's not I mean that's
obviously going to make a difference to
how you think about your beliefs in the
first place so taking this non rational
view has certain implications for how
you're then going to live your belief so
it can't run primarily emphasizes that
religious belief is about changing your
life and becoming a different sort of
person rather than acquiring particular
metaphysical beliefs so you know it's
not not necessarily about believing that
there's some sort of master of the
universe figure lurking behind the
scenes which isn't to say that bit
conjoin thinks there is no God I mean
sometimes one objection that's made to
the insurance conception is well you
know isn't basically abolishing religion
altogether is is this not just a
religion for atheists Susan he just
saying you know you don't need to
believe in God effectively to which the
response would be well if you think
there's only one thing that belief in
God could be namely to have some kind of
metaphysical belief about a sort of
bodyless master of the universe figure
if you think that's the only substance
that the religious belief could have
then it is true that bit constrain does
away with that but I think again it
would be too simplistic to take that
line I mean I think there are many
religious believers perhaps especially
more in the sort of mystical tradition
who don't think that God can be sort of
cashed out in in metaphysical form that
it's about sort of believing in some
kind of outlandish entity that the
grammar of God of the concept is is
quite different which isn't to say
that we can kind of settle on a priori
grants whether there is a god or not
I think forbid Kim Stein and that's how
it ties in to the non national part as
well ultimately it's a personal choice
whether you want to change your life
according to these you know religious
doctrines and you want to kind of try
and live them actualize them in your
life that has to be a personal question
it's if you like forbid condone more
analogous to making an ethical choice
rather than choosing to do something on
the basis of empirical evidence so a
religious belief is quite different on
victims on this view from any kind of
ordinary belief given how polarized the
contemporary debate has become I think
it's probably a good idea for people to
sit back and think a bit more about what
they actually think their beliefs mean
or what it is that they're arguing for I
think it would be good if people stopped
taking for granted that they necessarily
know what the full implications are even
of their own beliefs and you know
perhaps stop being quite so sure and so
sure that you know the other conception
has to be wrong so I think I mean that
that's I think one earth achill
dimension that that bit conjoin brings
to the mix but I think he also makes
possible a more mature deeper going
understanding of religion that just
isn't available if you take one or the
other side which admittedly I've you
know perhaps caricature just to kind of
make the point more obvious but I think
this third way that bit condign offers
makes religion potentially a viable
option even for people who think hard
about things and you know who don't want
to find easy answers and to say well you
know lack of empirical evidence settles
the question if it constrain is right
that religious beliefs ask different
sorts of questions then you know perhaps
the absence of
evidence isn't a huge problem because
that's not what it's about well I mean
it obviously seems a great thing to be
doing I mean getting the public to
engage with big ideas I mean is what
every academic wants to achieve I mean
it's what what we're trying to do when
educating students so you know bringing
these debates to to the wider public and
getting them to engage and think about
these things I mean I think is in
principle a highly laudable thing but
it's also going to be nice I mean I've
not had my debate yet but I'm looking
forward to talking to two interesting
people about a very serious question so
so I think it's all good get your
tickets for the world's largest music
and philosophy festival how the light
gets in aaaghh